beyond Europe we discussed the
negotiations over Iran's nuclear program
and we remain united heading into the
final stages of the talks Iran has a
historic opportunity to resolve the
international community's concerns about
its nuclear program and we agreed that
Iran needs to seize that opportunity our
discussions with Prime Minister Abadi of
Iraq President kyed assessee Tunisia and
President bihari of Nigeria were a
chance to address the threats of ISIL
and Boko Haram the g7 countries
therefore agreed to work together and
with our partners to further coordinate
our counterterrorism efforts as many of
the world's leading partners in global
development joined by leaders of
Ethiopia Liberia Nigeria Senegal and the
African Union we discussed how to
maximize the impact of our development
partnerships we agreed to continue our
landmark initiative to promote food
security and nutrition part of our
effort to lift 500 million people in
developing countries out of hunger and
malnutrition by 2030 we'll continue to
work with our partners in West Africa to
get Ebola cases down to zero and as part
of our global health security agenda I'm
pleased that the g7 made a major
commitment to help 60 countries over the
next five years achieve specific targets
to better prevent detect and respond to
future outbreaks before they become
epidemics and finally I want to commend
Chancellor Merkel for ensuring that the
summit included a focus on expanding
educational and economic opportunities
for women and girls the g7 committed to
expanding career training for women in
our own countries and to increase
technical and vocational training in
developing countries which will help all
of our nation's prosper so again I want
to thank Angela and the people of
Germany for their extraordinary
hospitality I leave here confident that
when it comes to the key challenges of
our time America and our closest allies
stand shoulder-to-shoulder